july 20th 2021
u.s senator rand paul and dr anthony
fauci got into a nasty fight on tv
about research that dr fauci's
organization funded
in wuhan china it's a dance and you're
dancing around this
because you're trying to obscure
responsibility rand paul claims that the
research was a dangerous type of gain of
function research
that had been banned in the u.s at that
time fauci responded by saying
senator paul you do not know what you
are talking about
both of them called each other liars and
if anybody is
lying here senator it is you
which one is right which one is
the liar obviously the dramatic music
was a joke
god my name is john perry i teach
biology
i specialize in genetics i have read all
of the research that these two men were
fighting about
it's very technical literature and i
imagine that a lot of people who aren't
trained in genetics are having trouble
getting through it and so my goal here
is to use nice clear graphics to explain
this research
so that you can figure out for
yourselves which one of these guys is
lying which one of these guys is telling
the truth or
you actually might find out that both of
them are telling
parts of the truth and reality is a
little bit
fuzzy there's something that i have to
say that i wish i didn't have to say and
that is it it drives me
absolutely nuts that anthony fauci
has become like the superstar the new
jesus
of the left the far left and has become
the new demon the devil
of the far right anthony fauci is just a
dude
working for the government doing medical
stuff he's been doing it for a long time
all we're going to do in this video is
we're going to figure out if
he funded gain of function research and
if he lied about that to congress that's
all we're going to do
this is not a like fanboy video for
anthony fauci
it's not a hate on anthony fauci video
we're just going to look at
facts that's it so let's dive in here
this is the research paper that rand
paul uses as evidence to support his
claim that dr
fauci funded gain of function research
in china
research so dangerous that the u.s had
banned its funding
back in 2014 so what did the chinese
researchers actually do
well what these researchers did is they
went out into the wild and collected a
bunch of coronaviruses
from bats then they sequenced those
coronavirus's genes
in the laboratory so far so good nothing
illegal has happened
here so far this is just normal virus
research
sort of stuff that you would see any
virology research group do
next they noticed that gene sequences in
some of the viruses
looked like they might code for spike
proteins
that could allow them to get inside
human cells
cells are covered in what we call
receptor proteins
there are many kinds of receptor
proteins that do different things for
different types of cells
here i'm showing you a cartoon version
of what is called
the human ace2 receptor coronaviruses
have spiked proteins
that are shaped in a way allowing them
to stick like velcro
to specific receptors on cells
the cell then swallows the virus and the
virus can start
replicating itself causing an infection
most
bat coronaviruses cannot get inside
human cells
because they cannot stick to the
receptors on human cells
their spiked proteins are shaped in a
way that they only stick to proteins
found in
bats in a human body they simply bounce
around
and eventually break apart the gene
sequence
in the newly discovered bat viruses
however
looked similar to gene sequences found
in viruses that infect humans
alarmed by this the chinese scientists
wanted to test the spiked proteins to
see if they really could work
on human cells to do this they took a
virus called
with one it is known to be super good at
entering human cells
in petri dishes no one's ever tried
actually putting them in a living human
because we don't want to get someone
sick but they do work at getting into
human cells
in petri dishes this is because their
spike proteins stick extremely well
to the human ace2 receptor the neat
thing about this virus is that
in earlier studies on mice it was
discovered that once the with
one virus gets inside a cell it
replicates
slowly it does not cause serious disease
it does not easily spread from mouse to
mouse and it is thought
that it would not easily spread from
human to human either
again they never tried it out on a human
so we don't know for sure but
the virus is considered to be relatively
safe in humans
now here is the part of the paper that
is a little bit questionable
using american money given to them by dr
fauci's organization
the chinese scientists took this virus
removed its spike protein genes
using gene editing techniques and
replaced them with the spike
genes from wild viruses that they had
found
then they tested to see if the
genetically engineered hybrid
what scientists call a chimera could
still get inside
human cells can these spike proteins
from viruses recently discovered in bats
actually work and allow a virus to get
inside of a human cell
it turns out that some of them could the
chinese researchers then published their
paper
warning the world that bats in china
contain many
potentially dangerous viruses so the
first question
i think is worth asking is this was that
research
dangerous that rand paul presented
yes that research was dangerous i mean
every time we go out and
collect viruses and then you know
cultivate those viruses in a laboratory
work with those viruses in a laboratory
it's dangerous someone could get sick
and you could
potentially cause a pandemic it's always
dangerous i do
appreciate rand paul bringing this to
the public's attention i
i award him a point the second question
is
did rand paul accurately describe
this research let's hear exactly how he
described it viruses that in nature only
infect
animals were manipulated in the wuhan
lab
to gain the function of infecting humans
no rand paul did not describe this
research accurately
the starting virus the one that was
actually engineered it was not just an
animal virus
it was a virus that was already well
known to efficiently enter
human cells because its spike proteins
are a perfect match for our human
ace2 receptors so given that
pretty big and important error that rand
paul made
i do think it's it's fair for dr
fauci to have said this senator paul you
do not know what you are talking about
rand paul also claims that this research
counts as gain of function research
according to dr fauci's own definition
and that funding this type of gainer
function research had been banned by the
federal government
when dr fauci's group approved funding
for this chinese research
is that true does this chinese research
count
as the type the specific type of gain of
function research that was actually
banned
in 2014 to 2017 let's take a look
at exactly what was banned in 2014.
this here is the actual document
announcing the ban of gain of function
research
and on page one of this document we have
the definition
new usg funding will not be released for
gain of function research projects
that may be reasonably anticipated to
confer attributes
to influenza mers or sars viruses
such that the virus would have enhanced
pathogenicity
so it makes it so it gets people more
sick and or
transmissibility in mammals via the
respiratory route
the research funding pause would not
apply to characterization
or testing of naturally occurring
influenza mers
and sars viruses unless the tests are
reasonably anticipated to increase
transmissibility and or pathogenicity
technically speaking that research that
was done in china does not qualify
as this type of gain of function
research and the reason for that is that
the with one virus first of all it's not
a sars virus it's a
sars like virus so it's
technically it's not covered in this ban
furthermore that virus was already able
to get inside of human cells
so by removing its spike protein which
is the tool that it used to get inside
of human cells
and replacing that spike protein with a
different spike protein that we found
from other viruses
that does not enhance its ability to get
inside of human cells it could already
do it
perfectly what we did is we were just
testing to see if these other spiked
proteins
could also let it get inside of human
cells this research
really wasn't any more dangerous
than just working with a virus that
could infect human cells
it the gain of function that was given
here
was not a gain of function that
increased the danger
of this virus in fact the genes that
make this virus
replicate slowly inside of a cell once
it gets inside those were not messed
with at all
so this was not
gain of function research according to
this definition so rand paul is wrong
here
again that said this
this doesn't count as gain of function
research really
on because of a technicality
i do think it's very important that
people understand
the research we're doing in laboratories
is dangerous
and it's important that we
we have a discussion about this that we
understand this
as members of the public that we
understand what's happening we
understand what the risks are
what the potential benefits are and i do
believe
that our government officials have done
a really poor job
explaining this to us in a way that the
average person
can understand so i do think that
fauci and crew need to step up their
game in public education
when he got in front of congress and
testified that we have never funded gain
of function research
in wuhan china yes he's technically
correct not
this type specific type of gain of
function research but we have funded
dangerous research in muhan china
and he should have made that clear when
he was
testifying he should have made that
clear and he didn't and i think that
that was
irresponsible at least in hindsight i
hope that he would
see that as well and you know i
it's this is the complicated issue
there's a lot of gray areas here and
i yeah i hope that you all can see that
now i hope this now makes sense
sweet dreams everybody subscribe to my
youtube channel and all